lucas gialito on for his 12th start he's
looking for his sixth win his era
about three and three quarters you look
at strikeouts you look at innings pitch
they're very good he's got good command
left-handers don't hit him at all
because of that change-up the kick the
one-two swing and a miss
on a nasty change-up he struck him out
for the first out of the day yeah great
combination you pointed out that he had
set up high on the previous pitch
and then colin set up low down and away
and that's where he executed the
changeup no score bottom of the first
derrick skubal youngster they really
like him he's on for his tenth start at
zra a bit above four and a half
over third base
ta likes the jerseys
he's on his way to second
it's a leadoff double for tim anderson
who's six for his last 15.
here's nick madrigal in his second major
league home run last night madrigal off
from now
into center
follow the bouncing ball to a
one-nothing lead
i think lucas is going to be treated to
a lot of runs today two hitters one run
but nick goes right back up the middle
like this is how we're gonna do it boys
on get him out we're gonna go score two
quick hits in a run that's how you teach
it if you're a white sox coach tigers
have the lead off man on here in the
second for eric haas
drives one to deep left field that ball
is gone
eric haas continues to beat up teams on
the road
the tigers have a 2-1 lead thanks to his
sixth homer of the year well this kid is
pretty darn hot himself we were talking
yesterday about jonathan scopes huge
night
but his home run is the home run that
put him ahead what does he do today on a
changeup he sits on a lucas giolito
changeup and it's a mistake pitch folks
right down the middle when you get those
mistake pitches we call them cookies you
gotta eat the cookie here is harold
castro left-handed batting shortstop
madrigal at second base nice pick
nikki's throw is there
spectacular effort from number one
that's just a great play going to his
right castro can't believe it he thought
he had a base hit all the way and nick
with good range and then the one hop
throw but he got just enough to cut down
castro at first
derek skubal goes to work in the bottom
of the second with a one-run lead faces
andrew vaughn
good slider right there strikes out
andrew vaughn to start the second get
ahead you can make quality pitches you
can expand the zone here this is the
slider back foot slider under the swing
of andrew vaughn and school will get
strikeout number two here three two with
checks
did he go yes he did appeal down to
first great gibson this time
goes up with the right hand collins
hitting 197 the 1-2
got him on the outside
perfectly executed slider derek squibble
strikes out the side in the second
inning good
good 2-1 tigers as we go to the top of
the fourth inning eric haas with the
home run first time up gave the tigers
the lead
some mad power sends this one to deep
left field back
that's gone again
he's unbelievable
to homer night for eric haas
and the tigers have increased their lead
to three to one
you know this ball is away and he still
goes out to pull it watch it i thought
it was off the end of the bed it's a
slider
and it hangs up there
but eric just again what a great swing
the hands break free right upon contact
and this ball travels just far enough
clear the wall and left field third
multi-homer game of the season for eric
haas let's take a look at the overall
performance from tarik today
you see the variety of pitches that have
worked fastball up the slider down
slider down again
a good slider to the left-hander
he's gone with that fastball
ten strikeouts like shep said and we're
only one out into the fifth inning four
and a third innings of work with ten
strikeouts oh and two on
johan manchadi seen a slider and a
fastball scuba pitch count climbing in a
jam in the fifth the o2 is swinging in a
mess he got him with a fastball up and
away
11th strikeout for terek scooper three
walks 11 strikeouts one run on four hits
for the white sox this is the end of his
day
cabrera singled and scored in the second
grounded to short his last time up the
01
off the end of the bat sounded good
right center field back it goes it's
gone
number 492
for miguel cabrera and the tigers now
lead it 4-1
just the way that ball jumped off the
bat boy
it's bombs away in chicago right now
the ball is flying out of there jack he
put a nice swing and you can see the
ball just jump off his back
fastball
away and see that's what happens guys
when you stay away with the big fellas
guys that have power
they like to get extended and when you
can get some extension
you can hit the ball a long way and
that's exactly what miggy does here
that's a big run guys that's a huge run
second and third nobody out and the
tying run will come to the plate
jake lamb
to right field this will bring home two
and the socks are on the comeback trail
and storming down it four to three
pollen is lovely this time of year
jake getting his first opportunity to
swing the bat today in because hamilton
hurt himself he gets one out over the
plate takes it into right field makes it
a one-run game welcome back to the
ballpark derek howard and they turn it
over to gregory soto in this inning he
will face andrew vaughn jake lamb and
zach collins the one-two swing and a
miss on that dynamite slider 89 under
the bat of a right this is a big inning
right here we do not need to turn this
line up over
the one two
[Music]
another one down on strikes down on the
bottom of the zone after going inside
this guy has seen a lot of pitches with
two strikes this is an eight pitch at
bat already
stroke to left field back goes
has room
and soto wins that battle with mercedes
chicago goes one two three chicago's
last hope nick madrigal
don't be afraid of contact
here's the payoff
out of line to willy castro and the
tigers win it by one well he challenged
him with the fastball
mandergo hit it hard
but it found a glove and the tigers
found a win
they'll take it strong pitching
especially by starter tarik skubal and
another strong offensive performance
from eric haas